getting people to a state of mind where
they are able to have really effective
communication with others because if you
just say to someone okay say these
things and use your body language in
this way and it will work it won't
because there are elements in their
mindset and their mental health that may
be holding them back from that they need
to work on first such that they can be a
really positive influence on others a
way of thinking about this for people is
to think about the emotional comfort
zone that we have so if you feel some
sense of anxiety about there being like
a difficult discussion and people having
different opinions the opposite of that
is to always spend time with people who
just sort of go along with what you say
and just agree with you which is no good
for anybody it's a bit like going to the
gym and deciding to pick up weights that
feel like feathers to you and you know
pretend that that's a workout and go
home well you know you're going to get
atrophy in your muscles that they're not
going to work as well the same goes for
our emotional strength but if we only go
into situations that are within our
comfort zone what happens is our comfort
zone actually shrinks it doesn't stay
the same size so the comfort someone
says okay I'm only willing to do the
things that were most comfortable
yesterday and it suddenly gets shrunken
and the challenge with that is that
you're suddenly living in such a tight
living space that you can't help but be
upset by almost everything because
you're bouncing into or bumping into the
edges of the comfort zone every day so
we have to be able to carefully step by
step expand with that emotional comfort
zone feels like to a place where we can
you know have those uncomfortable
conversations
[Music]
that was Richard Newman the keynote
speaker coach speechwriter and
award-winning expert in communication
storytelling and influence he also
happens to be the husband of Dr Gemma
Newman the past guest on my podcast
collaborator for my birth course and
both are friends of mine Richard Newman
is an introvert on the autism spectrum
who dedicated decades to understanding
and improving communication at 18 he
lived in the foothills of the Himalayas
teaching English to Tibetan Monks where
they had no common language between them
so they had to communicate through
non-verbal signals to understand each
other he is now the CEO and founder of
UK bodytalk a global leader in training
on the science of communication his team
has coached over a hundred and twenty
thousand people from companies including
Microsoft London Business School NYU and
many more Fortune 500 companies he also
created one of the largest studies on
non-verbal communication and influence
ever made which was published in the
peer-reviewed Journal of Psychology his
research proved that you can increase
the number of people you're able to
influence by 42 percent with just small
adjustments in your behavior which is
incredible when you think about it his
new book lift your impact shows how
transforming your mindset and actions
can help you thrive and enjoy a greater
sense of purpose and fulfillment in your
life this episode covers how to
cultivate healthy Communication in all
kinds of relationships including work
romantic family and friends how to
communicate peacefully with those you
disagree with to create a positive
outcome the connection between mental
health and communication important
strategies everyone can use before
important conversations to ensure a
better outcome the age of digital
communication and how it can lead to
surface level relationships how to avoid
conflict by recognizing the difference
between the facts and the story that
your ego tells you and how to be a
change maker and do meaningful work I
love everything about this important
topic I had such a great time talking to
him and I hope you enjoy our
conversation welcome to the Ellen Fisher
podcast
have you guys tried the anima Moody
herbals chocolate protein powder yet it
is so yummy and it's made with protein
pumpkin seed protein and rice protein
it's designed for energy strength
stamina and resilience and it tastes so
good in smoothies or your favorite baked
goods like muffins if you don't know
what anema Moody herbals is it's an
apothecary founded by Costa Rican
herbalist Adriana ayalas that carries
organic wild crafted and ethically grown
Botanicals every vibrant and medicinally
potent remedy is packaged in
eco-friendly packaging of recyclable
glass or biodegradable bags over 200
different sustainably grown herbs are
used from around the world to create
intentional products that contain zero
fillers binders or flow agents
everything is made in the U.S with
certified organic wild crafted and
sustainably harvested plants and herbs
in a vegan and gluten-free kitchen I
also love their High potency Elderberry
syrup which is double extracted it's
adaptogenic antiviral organic and wild
crafted perfect for supporting healthy
immune function so use my code Ln 20 for
20 off just click the link in my show
notes to get this deal from an amazing
company that supports Fair Trade
Practices Beyond organic farming
education and small Farmers to create
remedies that benefit people from all
walks of life thank you Richard for
being here I am so excited for this
conversation I love the topic of healthy
communication and I think so many people
struggle with it so let's Dive Right In
yeah thanks when I was a child I was
described as being very shy I'm highly
highly introverted and I'm also autistic
and I was only diagnosed autistic uh
just about a year or so ago and when I
got that diagnosis it suddenly made
sense of so much of my life and so many
events that I wasn't really able to
understand or explain until that
diagnosis came through so to give you
know more of the full story behind that
when I was four years old about to
become five years old my family moved
house and we we went to this new school
and I remember vividly that day in that
that new school of trying to connect
with other children trying to
communicate with them and then sort of
looking at me and looking away and maybe
laughing giggling going somewhere else
and I just felt like I was in some kind
of glass bubble I didn't know how to
connect with anybody else and no matter
how loudly I try to express myself
nothing was resonating with people and I
burst into tears in sort of a terrible
first day sort of story and I'm sure you
know many people have that first day at
school sort of tough story but but in my
case I wasn't really sure what it was I
just knew that I wasn't I wasn't able to
connect and communicate in the same way
as other people and you know throughout
my years at school and growing up and
being a teenager I often found this to
be the case where other people could
have conversations like banter back and
forth and uh you know have relationships
with with girlfriends romantic partners
and do things that I I just wasn't able
to figure it out and an example of this
is for me when I see other people do uh
banter if it's polite friendly banter
with good intention what I see is two
people saying negative things about each
other and then laughing in the other
person's face and that's how I translate
it in my autistic brain and when I try
to do that back and you know it doesn't
end up going that well so I've had to
think about well what is it that other
people are doing in communication that's
working that I'm not doing how do I
figure this piece out and so when I was
around 16 years old a friend of mine
bought me a book called body language
which is sort of the original book on
Body Language by Alan Pease and I read
it and I was totally amazed by it I was
fascinated by every page thinking wow
this is the thing that I have been
missing and then I started to think well
well maybe everybody else already knows
this maybe I'm the only one that can't
figure this stuff out but I started to
use it started to apply it started to
get some results from it and as a result
of that I then read and studied over 200
books on communication over the sort of
the decade decade that followed looking
at various different things around body
language and voice and interactions with
people uh around stage presence and
Minds certain loads of other things that
help with communication and meanwhile I
did something which was a pivotal uh
experience in my life where aged 18 I
decided I would go to live in the
foothills of the Himalayas up in
Northeast India where I was living with
a group of Tibetan Monks and I was there
teaching them English and I'd chosen to
do this because I've always cared about
serving others and giving back to others
in some way and I knew I'd had a nice
upbringing I wanted to go and do
something of good what I learned from
the experience when I was there is that
the monks didn't speak any English when
I arrived so I had to rely entirely on
non-verbal communication so through my
body language and toner voice to
communicate and so what I mean by that
is that if I was trying to teach them
some English like I was trying to teach
them the word excited if I didn't look
excited and I didn't sound excited then
they didn't know what I was teaching
them so I had to have totally congruent
communication to get anything through
and by the end of the six months it was
an incredible experience they learned
how to speak English I learned how to
speak Nepali which was the main language
of the area that I was in I came back to
the UK just fascinated by what I'd
learned I then studied acting for three
years in London in an acting school
there and then set up my Communication
business really as a hobby I was because
I was just so fascinated with the
communication and it's grown from that
little hobby up to now where we have
about 2 000 bookings every year for our
team to go and do training events and
help people and Coach people in
communication all the way around the
world so it's really been a you know
massive Journey for me and I'm still
utterly passionate about communication
because I can see how small changes
little tools that I can give people make
such a difference to them to be able to
feel like they're finally being heard or
they're finally connecting with other
people so yeah that's that's kind of in
my journey on it so far amazing can you
explain maybe the art of communication
what are the pitfalls that people
experience because I think a lot of
people hear that word and they might not
really even ignore know exactly what you
mean that why this topic is so important
how it affects your life so much when I
hear the word healthy communication I
immediately go to maybe conflict
conversations and how to communicate
healthfully to have a mutually
respectful a fruitful conversation a
conversation that's even enjoyable even
with disagreeing on a topic that's kind
of where my mind goes but I know that
that's not maybe where everybody's mind
goes so can you just lay the ground or
for what are all the different facets
about this topic of communication for me
communication really comes down to our
ability to connect with other people and
you know the the antithesis of that is
that just a state of being alone and
disconnected and it's that state that
that I felt as a child of being in sort
of in a glass bubble where I didn't feel
like I could connect with other people
people I didn't feel like I was hurt by
other people I didn't know how to get an
interaction to work and it was it was a
devastating sort of feeling and I've
always wanted to move people away from
that because you know the truth is today
that people can be surrounded by other
people and still not feel connected with
them or understood or or know how to get
their thoughts across or know how to
have a positive disagreement and a
discussion whereas we know the opposite
of that where sometimes you know we can
have a fantastic evening with friends
where we sit around we have dinner and
we argue and debate about all the
different issues in the world about
politics religion the meaning of life
and we may all disagree with each other
but have an extraordinary time we come
home on a complete yeah feeling deeply
connected and fulfilled by this human
interaction that we've had and so human
connection is so important to us that if
we don't feel that as a baby as a child
if we don't feel connected with another
human we get that sensation of failure
to thrive as it's called so later on in
life if we don't feel connected with the
people around us heard or appreciated if
we don't feel our opinion is cared about
or understood that can lead to us
feeling uh very lonely disconnected from
our tribe wanting to leave being with a
group of friends or leave a company
where we're working because we don't
feel that the communication is working
so for me communication has to be deep
connection and importantly I'll say on
this too with communication something
that's so important recently I've
noticed a lot of people having much more
surface level conversations with people
where it's just sort of uh transactional
and there is less of the depth that's
going on and because of that people can
still feel a bit empty from an
interaction with somebody else because
they don't feel like there's actually
been anything meaningful that is going
on in the interaction between them so
it's so important to be able to fully
express yourself feel able to express
what your ideas are what your opinions
are even if somebody else doesn't agree
with them and be able to hear theirs as
well hear their point of view I know
that particularly in the states at the
moment it's talked about a lot that
there is a divided America with people
going into that place of only sort of
listening to people within their bubble
and only agreeing with those people and
people outside of that bubble art the
enemy and so on and we've got to get
back to a place where we are willing to
sit with each other in disagreement and
I have to say you know in this context
I'm reminded of I have these brilliant
people a couple of people I work with on
my leadership team who I love completely
and we disagree with each other
passionately every week and it's an
incredible relationship and we feel
heard by each other and we feel
respected by each other and we love
working with each other because we're
able to have that passionate expression
and openness and healthy disagreements
with each other that make us a stronger
leadership team for for our company as a
result yeah I think what you're saying
this example with the people in your
leadership Community is a rare one so
few people at least the people that I've
experienced in the world even want to
engage with discourse where you disagree
with someone and I think a lot of that
stems from fear fear of how they'll be
perceived fear of how the conversation
will go and maybe a lot of that stems
from their experiences in the past that
hey when I expressed my opinion that was
different to someone else's I didn't
receive respect or openness or love and
so that teaches them next time oh my
feelings aren't safe I need to hold
myself in and it dictates their future
conversations with who they meet
especially people where they don't know
if it's safe to be themselves so that
leads to more surface level interactions
which can feel for me at least straining
to have non-interesting conversations
whereas if I get in a room with someone
who wants to talk about things with me
that they disagree with with me I thrive
off of it I get energy from it but some
people feel less energy from or they
feel drained from conversations where
they're disagreeing with someone so what
do you think stems from that yeah yeah
so many things come up from what you're
saying there one thing that made me
smile is that there's a friend of ours
friend of the family who he gets invited
so much to you know different parties
dinner parties everybody really wants
him to be there because he makes a point
of passionately disagreeing with
whatever the consensus of opinion is in
the room and he loves that he loves that
sort of Riles up a conversation and he
does it with a smile on his face knowing
that like he may believe in what he's
saying or he may really not believe in
it but he loves what happens as a result
of building up the discussion that then
happens rather than everybody's sort of
Happily nodding along with each other to
come back to that sense of you know
making sure that people have these
healthy conversations the first bit I
wanted to address there is that if you
if you feel like you haven't been safe
in the past and you've been hurt because
of it when you've tried to express
yourself it's certainly a place that I
was in in the past what we do in that
situation is that we tend to build up
armor as I think of it and so we decide
okay I don't want to be hurt in that
next situation so I'm going to put my
arm on and the more times that you do
that the more armor you build up the
more heavy you end up feeling and also
the more disconnected and isolated you
feel from other people I'm many years
back when I was studying as an actor I
was feeling very much that way with sort
of friends family people are studying
with I just felt that I wasn't able to
connect with others or be understood and
built up all this armor kept everybody
at arm's length and I got to the point
where I was feeling suicidal and I raise
it because I know so many people there's
been a massive increase in the last
couple of years of people either
committing suicide or considering
suicide and I want to make sure that
people know that you know you can come
back from that place and one of those
pieces is that you have to get to a
place of taking the armor off so that
you can feel connected with other people
and feel the care and the love of other
people that you don't realize is there a
big breakthrough moment for me was a
lady who I was studying with at acting
school she came in early one day I'd
arrived early I can't remember why she
arrived early we're the only two people
there and she said to me uh Richard I
need to tell you something I had a dream
last night that you died and everybody
was devastated and I just wanted to know
how much we care about you and that was
her way of saying look I see the armor
that you're hiding behind and I want to
just reach out and connect with you and
let's have a conversation and sort of
ironically he was the person in the in
the group that I I got on leased with
who I felt maybe more defensive with and
she took that moment to sort of give
that Olive Branch to express a real
feeling that suddenly brought me back
and got me to a point where I talked and
I took the armor off and I was able to
build up a greater sense of connection
so I would always encourage people if
you're feeling that you're building up
that armor just know that people can see
the armor and they can steal the pet see
the pain they want to connect with you
you have to be able to trust just to put
some of that armor down but there's
there's other things that people can do
as well to prepare themselves for tough
conversations because
we need to not walk away from those
situations when there is a difficult
moment something that's a conflict of
sorts in our family with friends with
our colleagues we need to be able to
approach it and not everyone is going to
be like that lady who I studied with an
acting school of wanting to be so
supportive and so we do need to find a
way to uh to Center ourselves to really
ground ourselves and to be able to be if
you like a rock in the storm such that
no matter what is coming towards us from
you know other people's emotions that we
feel ready for that such that we can
then be our best version of ourselves in
those moments so that we then have a
positive experience and from that we can
think wow okay I you know I express
myself I allowed them to express
themselves and we moved forward in a
positive way and you can then build on
that with levels of confidence in the
future
yes oh I love what you just said and
going back to that scenario of your
friend who is always looking to play
Devil's Advocate at the dinner table and
get into discussions where you disagree
so many people will just hear that and
get anxiety just even thinking about
that the thought of being in a room
where people are all disagreeing a lot
of people get anxiety from that so I'm
so excited to get into these techniques
that people can use when a conversation
comes up where someone brings up
something they disagree with and they
can learn how to not hide themselves and
still be themselves and enjoy it because
you can sense it in the room anytime any
group of people it could even just be
two people and you're having a
conversation and as soon as maybe I'll
say something that the other person
disagrees with they don't even have to
say anything but you can sense based on
their body language based on just it's
like an energy that you feel from the
person you're speaking to if they're
feeling tense by what you just said or
if they're feeling calm and relaxed by
what you just said and it helps to know
if you can keep going with what you're
saying and keep going with your thought
process or if you need to shift years oh
this person doesn't feel comfortable
with where this conversation is going
let's change it to something lighter and
that is just fascinating to me how much
you can even sense how someone is
feeling on what you're saying even
without them saying anything at all yeah
so I mean a way of thinking about this
for people is to think about the
emotional comfort zone that we have so
if you feel some sense of anxiety about
there being like a difficult discussion
and people having different opinions the
opposite of that is to always spend time
with people who just sort of go along
with what you say and just agree with
you which is which is no good for
anybody it's a bit like going to the gym
and deciding to pick up weights that
feel like feathers to you and you know
pretend that that's a workout and go
home well you know you're going to get
atrophy in your muscles that they're not
going to work as well the same goes for
our emotional strength that if we only
go into situations that are within our
comfort zone what happens is our comfort
zone actually shrinks it doesn't stay
this same size so the comfort zone says
okay I'm only willing to do the things
that were most comfortable yesterday and
it suddenly gets shrunken and the
challenge with that is that you're
suddenly living in such a tight living
space that you can't help but be upset
by almost everything because you're
bouncing into or bumping into the edges
of the comfort zone every day so we have
to be able to carefully step by step
expand what that emotional comfort zone
feels like to a place where we can you
know have those uncomfortable
conversations and so one of those pieces
that's important here is for people to
think about uh internal validation
versus external validation and so if
we're going into an environment of
having a conversation with family
friends at a party whatever it may be
and we're sort of hoping that everybody
agrees with us part of that is we're
hoping for external validation that will
make us feel good about ourselves that
will make us feel accepted in some way
and when we're focused on external
validation it leads us to a state of
stress so uh you know one of those
examples is I'm sure everybody's done
this at some point but if you post
something on Instagram and 12 minutes
later you take a look at seeing you know
how many likes it's got and if it's only
got 100 likes and you feel upset then
you're looking for external validation
it can make you feel uh really unhappy
there was a really fascinating study on
this that was done by Creswell and
Sherman back in 2015 in Germany they did
a series of experiments called the try a
social stress test was the protocol they
were using in essence what they found is
that if they sent people into really
difficult situations like a tough job
interview or or doing a tough
presentation or getting a math exam or
something like that where they're trying
to impress a panel they're trying to get
accepted for a job or something they
found that those people who are looking
for external validation when they left
that experience their heart rate was
spiking their adrenaline and their
cortisol was going through the roof as
well cortisol being the main stress
hormone in the body they felt deeply
stressed because they were put in this
environment particularly by their
experiments they told the panel don't
give them good feedback shake your head
say they're not good enough and ask them
to leave the room and people felt
terrible they tried it with another
group where they said you're going to go
through the same experience but before
you go in write a page about your
personal values just choose your top
three values or principles you care
about in life and write about how
they've guided you and what they mean
for you and why you're so proud of
yourself for caring about these values
and they did that they then went through
the same horrible experience and their
heart rate didn't change they didn't
have any uptick in cortisol or
adrenaline they felt completely fine
through it and the reason being they
were not looking for external validation
they had the internal validation so I
say this is a long way around of saying
if people are going to approach a tough
conversation where people may disagree
one of the key ways that you can prepare
for that and Prime yourself is before
you go into it just remind yourself
about the values that you deeply care
about who are you as a person give
yourself internal validation and to give
an example so my my number one value in
life is to be good parent for whatever
reason I don't know where it came from
or why I've always cared about it but
it's very meaningful to me and I think
about what that means to me I also care
about inspiring and empowering my
clients which I think of as being the
oxygen for them and I also care about
being the Silverback for my team of
being able to provide for them and
protect them in different ways I think
about these values and I get rooted in
okay I know who I am I don't need
external validation these are principles
that if I live by them I'll go to sleep
happy and then you can go into that
tough conversation where people have
totally different opinions and really
disagree with you and you can stay
centered in who you are and just really
listen and objectively take on board
what they have to say and there's
various other pieces we can talk about
about you know allowing emotional safety
in that conversation but allows you to
stay centered not from a position of
needing others to agree with you but
feeling safe to express who you are
because you know you're speaking from
your values and I think so much of what
you're saying for people if they can go
into conversations like this they'll
have an easier time listening to others
as well and not feeling threatened by
the conversation and your energy of
staying calm and feeling
centered and at peace and respectful of
yourself and others helps the other
person to stay calm and at peace as well
because as soon as one person's energy
heightens it's more likely for the other
person's energy and stress to heighten
as well I mean we all know this in
romantic relationships family
relationships even friendship
relationships actually all relationships
because now I'm like and work
relationships yeah exactly right and you
know this has been a big lesson that
I've learned being a parent I've been a
parent for 11 years now and I know that
if there's challenges happening within
my family particularly with my children
that they're emotional and get upset
about something the most important thing
I can do is to show up sent it to the
conversation and allow their emotion to
be expressed allow them to feel safe
that they can do that and for me to be
there to be able to even if I you know
agree or disagree with whatever is going
on or how they've acted and so on just
allow them to be heard in that moment
and to be able to talk them through the
situation such that I understand what's
happened how they felt what it means to
them what we can do about it next what
are they learning from this that's got
to come from me priming myself and the
great privilege of staying with you
Ellen just over a year ago I guess it
was and seeing what brilliant parents
you and Andrew are with you know many
more children than we have and so you
know seeing seeing how brilliant you are
at being present with them and being
able to guide their emotions and their
needs day to day was you know utterly
inspiring I think about this when I walk
into challenging situations at work and
with other people in my family thinking
if this is going to go well I must be
the centered version of myself first I
need to be working on priming myself
from the moment that I wake up in the
morning and being aware of what takes me
away from that because of this diagnosis
of being uh autistic I've suddenly
become aware of certain things like I
know that if I have a lot of coffee and
a lot of sugar I get a serious sensory
overwhelm and that throws me off no
matter how I'm trying to guide it most
with people so I know that if there's a
day where there's an important
conversation coming up for me no
caffeine no sugar those are just an
absolute because I want to be a good
version of me I also do that if I'm
going on stage and I'm going to speak to
a thousand people for an hour I know
that there's going to be a lot of
sensory overwhelm from that experience
so no caffeine no sugar get some
exercise get some fresh air focus in on
my values work on my breathing and then
I go in and I can be the best version of
myself for everybody else and allow them
to feel safe to do and be whatever they
need to be in that situation as well
love that those are great tips and in
this conversation of communication I
kind of want to lump it into two
different categories but let me know
what you think because my thoughts on
difficult conversations stem from one
when you're disagreeing with someone
about a particular issue it could be
like you said politics religion the
meaning of life all that type of thing
or then the other could be like a hard
conversation would be when it comes up
unexpectedly and you're having an
argument with your spouse or a work
conflict or something with your friend
that is a misunderstanding of what
happened so do you navigate those types
of conversations in the same way and are
there or are there different types of
techniques to handle through that yeah
so first of all to talk about if
something comes up that is unexpected in
a conversation that feels important it's
hard for you to sort of prepare yourself
to be Centered for that situation which
is where I always encourage people to
think about really look after yourself
from the beginning of each day get
yourself to a place where you feel
grounded in who you are whether that is
yoga or meditation or whatever you need
to do a morning smoothie something
that's going to Prime you because we
don't know what life is going to throw
at us and so we want to be in a position
where we can respond well in those
situations the next stage of talking
about those is that for me as I look at
communication it's simply about two
human beings needing to find a way to
connect with each other and so there's
so much that's a thread that goes all
the way through you know how you
interact with with your boss at work how
you interact with your children how you
interact with remember antique partners
and so on there's a thread that goes
through that because we're all humans
trying to connect with other humans and
we all have human wants and needs and
desires and so on but if they're if
there's say a serious challenge that
comes up which could be maybe an
intimate partner it could be someone who
you work very closely with and you're
not expecting it to happen the first
thing that I would recommend that people
do is just recognize where are you at
the moment in terms of your ability to
react and to deal with this situation
are you in a place where you feel I can
move forward with this conversation
right now and it's going to have a great
conclusion or are you feeling that
suddenly your your ego is flaring up
your emotions are flaring that you know
they've caught you after you just had
your fourth coffee that morning and
there's also other stress that you're
dealing with like there's a deadline
that's coming up all these other pieces
that could lead to a pressure in that
situation where you suddenly feel very
stressed and angry very quickly and the
challenge with that is that sometimes we
think I'm justified in thinking stressed
I'm justified in feeling angry because
this person made me feel this way before
that happens you need to think where am
I at before this conversation there's a
way around this that I've heard people
use which I really like which is a red
Amber or green situation where if
someone raises a challenging uh topic
with you where you feel okay I'm
probably not in the right situation to
deal with this right now you can let
them know look right now is not going to
be a great time for me to be the best
version of me and respond to you I
really care about you I want to hear
about this emotion and I really care
about where this relationship goes what
I would really love to do is just take a
moment and come back to this
conversation you don't have to say that
I'm in a red situation I'm in an Amber
situation but you can just think to
yourself do I feel green right now do I
feel like everything's going to be okay
and I can get a good outcome and if not
let them know that you really do care
about them and you want to find time and
the key thing to this is do not do that
silly thing that people do in business
all the time these days of saying let's
just take this offline and put a pin in
it or whatever that expression is which
basically means we're never going to
come back to that conversation the
person thinks you're fobbing them off
what you need to be able to do is to say
look I'd love to have this conversation
with you let's talk about when is going
to be a great time for both of us can we
find a time later today is is that going
to be all right with you so the person
feels cared for and then you need to
show up reliably for them at that point
and not postpone it any further so that
you're able to come in when you do then
come into that situation there's a few
other things to think about so firstly
to Prime yourself before you go in one
piece that people can do if they're
thinking oh I just I'm feeling tight and
anxious and I don't really want to have
this conversation something I learned as
an actor which has always been powerful
in my life is that your breathing
changes how you feel and I remember this
distinctly where there was an actress
who was being coached uh back when I was
at acting school where at the end of one
scene she was supposed to be laughing
hysterically having a great time at the
beginning of the next scene she was
supposed to be breaking down in tears
and she'd said to our head of acting I
don't know how to do that like like how
could I possibly do that the next scene
is like a year later I don't know how to
do this and the acting teacher said you
do it through your breathing and so she
coached us all on how to cry on cue and
how to Laugh On Cue by mimicking the
breath that would happen there which
which triggers you into that state and
so you can do the same thing of doing
the breath of complete relaxation and
there's a couple of ways of doing this I
quite like box breathing which is
sometimes known as Square breathing
because it's nice to regulate your
breathing and your heart rates and and
to get rid of adrenaline there's also
something that's talked about a lot at
the moment called physiological sites
which is where you do two breaths in and
then a full sigh out which is something
we've got this beautiful dog Rosie who's
a cockapoo and you can see this you can
see her doing this in a moment of
complete relaxation on the floor and
kids do this as well when they're sort
of about to have a deep sleep is they
they breathe in
another breath in and then a big
and everything relaxes and there's some
nice evidence around this that if you do
a physiological size as it's called for
five minutes you can still feel the
impact 24 hours later because it's so
effective so you can do that before you
go in the next piece I'll talk about
when you go into the room
you want to create a sense of safety for
the other person to express themselves
and part of the way that you do that is
to talk about intention so what is your
intention in showing up for this meeting
where would you love for this to go if
it's a difficult conversation with
someone who you think is stressed at
work and thinking that they don't want
to work there anymore if you think it's
someone stressed in your relationship or
friendship with you and they want to
express something uh with you then talk
about you know what is your intention
towards them where would you love to be
which could be along the lines of thank
you so much for just giving me an hour
to to deal with some other things so I
can give you time in this conversation
and you know just so you know my
intention in whatever you want to share
with me is I'd like to have the best
possible relationship with you I want to
talk about you know where we can have a
positive future together I'm I'm here
for you I'm here to listen to you so
they they feel like oh okay good I know
where you're coming from I don't have to
second guess that and sort of wonder if
I can trust you or if I'm safe with you
and then you're allow you're allowing
space for them to then speak to you most
likely on a less heightened level so you
can move that conversation forward
hopefully to a more positive resolution
oh those are such great techniques and
tips I was just going to lead into okay
what are specific things we can say to
help keep a conversation respectful so
the person feels loved by you and there
you go you just went into it something
you said earlier was about our ego and I
thought that was really fascinating one
because I relate to my own experience
I'm hearing what you're saying I'm
relating to myself and for me when I go
into a conversation or a conversation
happens to come up about something that
someone disagrees with I find energy
from that and part of that is because I
feel safe I feel like I'm going to be
understood because I know how to
communicate my feelings to the other
person in a way that they will be able
to understand but when it comes to a
relational disagreement like with my
partner it can very easily become
heightened because one our ego gets in
the way where we're thinking no I'm
right and this is not what happened or
whatever and then the other thing thing
is the feeling of being misunderstood
there's a fear that comes up for me with
maybe specific types of relationships
like oh no I'm going to be misunderstood
in this experience so how can we best
convey our feelings in a way that's
going to be understood best and also for
them to receive it best yeah great
question and so this is where I talk to
people about the three levels of a
conversation so just just to set this up
first of all I'm sure people are
familiar with the analogy there's a
picture that you can see online about
this of different people being
blindfolded and then walking towards an
elephant and needing to to touch various
parts of it and some people saying oh
it's like a long hose and other people
saying no no it's like a rope oh no it
feels like a great big reptile and
they're touching different parts of it
they're all correct every single one of
them is correct but they're just coming
at it from their own different
perspective the same goes in situations
where there is conflict both of you can
be completely correct from your
perspective and it's just you know where
you happen to be touching which part of
the elephant you're at so before you go
into that situation there's a few things
that you can do firstly just understand
that if there's heightened emotions
going on the ego may be playing a part
and assumptions and exaggerations maybe
playing a part and so what our ego tends
to do our ego is great for our survival
we all need to have a healthy ego
sometimes the ego gets a little bit out
of control particularly in a state of
conflict and the ego will say things
like uh you know I'm the greatest at
this and I'm the best at this and I am
right in this situation and it's doing
those things for a sense of protection
but actually it can lead us to all sorts
of problems so before you approach a
conversation what can be really useful
to do is to write down what is your
story about this because what we we're
all these meaning makers we love story
as a way of translating what's happening
into a series of events so you can write
down what is the story and why are you
so upset about it and write it out in
full like it's this epic dramatic story
that you're going to sell to Hollywood
for Millions like what is this epic
Story look like and then you go back
through it and you have to delete every
single word in there that's an emotion
you have to delete everything in there
that's an exaggeration so such as uh if
you say a word in there like always you
always do this well that's most likely
to be nonsense unless you're talking
about the sun always Rising saying that
you always do this and I always do that
is unlikely so you delete exaggerations
you delete uh emotional words and you
delete anything that's an assumption if
you don't have Crystal Clear hard facts
that you could prove in a court you
delete it and you say well what am I
left with and what you're left with then
is a selection of facts where you think
okay I think that these things are
accurate from my perspective and there's
a bunch of stuff that I now actually I'm
not sure if I know or not and so the
other piece that you can then do is to
think I need to get really curious about
what are the pieces of this story that
I'm missing a bit like a German this
might approach something thinking I
don't know this piece and I'm not sure
what that piece would be and I wonder
why from their perspective they acted in
that way and that gives you some nice
questions to come into the conversation
with with complete non-judgment to think
if I was in their life and I'd act in
that way I wonder why that happened you
know what what is what is the meaning
behind that what drove that piece so
that allows you to come in from that
Curiosity perspective rather than an
accusational perspective and as you then
come into the conversation and you're
asking those questions that the key
thing to look for is the three levels of
a conversation so three levels are facts
feelings and motives and they're all
important in different ways and
unfortunately when we have conversations
with people we're often missing one of
those that leads to a negative outcome
so let's say that we go into a
conversation and we just deal with
feelings and somebody says I feel this
the other person says yeah well I feel
this well that's crazy that you feel
this why do you feel this you shouldn't
feel that because you're feeling that
makes me feel this and it just goes back
and forth and so it's not useful instead
what we can add in there is facts where
we can have a sense of you know I I want
to talk to you about this situation this
is what I'm aware of at the moment these
are the facts that I think are happening
can I check in with you are those the
factors you see it or are there other
pieces that I'm missing here so you can
have those facts then to create a zone
of safety when you talk about feelings
it's really important not to say you
made me feel and because whenever we say
you made me feel we are completely
disempowering ourselves we're saying you
know I whatever I do in my life is a
result of other people's actions which
makes us feel like a pinball and a
pinball machine it's not useful so
instead we can go with a fact-based
situation of this happened when this
happened second level of the
conversation is the feeling when this
happened I felt this which is truth
whether it's the right feeling to have
or the wrong feeling had to have or the
person disagrees with it it's your
feeling so you can own it when this
happened I felt this and then the third
part of the conversation that needs to
happen to really be effective there is
that you have to get down to the stage
of the motives and the drivers behind
the actions and so the way you present
this is you say fact level when this
happened feeling level I felt this and
the motive level is then that mattered
to me so much because and you share with
them what is the key driving part of
that what is the most important
principle that's really at stake in this
situation so you've got fact feeling and
motives and when you do that it helps
the other person understand you and
there's no accusation in there and it
also leaves them open to the opportunity
and you can ask them questions around
I'd love to know the facts from your
perspective what did you see feel and
experience what was that like for you
what are your thoughts about it and what
is the most important driving principle
for you and getting down to that driving
principle is something I work on with
people in work situations a lot because
often people say look these are the
facts these are the numbers we have to
hit these kpis off you go and they're
not dealing with the feelings or how
people feel you know underneath that
well they're drivers either but it also
happens in relationships with people
misunderstand each other because they
express emotions back and forth and they
think well surely that's what we're
supposed to be doing but they're sort of
missing well what is actually driving
this underneath what is the principle
that's really at stake for this person
and when you know what that principle is
you start to deepen your relationship
and then your behavior towards them can
change knowing that is deeply important
to them a sense of fairness it might be
or a sense of feeling significant to you
a sense of Integrity or whatever is the
deepest driving piece for them when you
know what it is it can help solve and be
a domino for future conversations when
you see them acting in a way that made
you feel upset in some way and there's
another conflict coming up you can think
wait a second what are the deepest
driving values that lead to these
conflicts and now that I know what that
is I now have a better way of
understanding where this may come from
and a better way to to feel that I can
resolve the conflict so it's those three
levels of conversation that we need to
make sure that we're checking in with
with our family our friends and the
people we work with I love the way that
you explain those three different levels
and the specifics of things like asking
questions remaining curious saying
things like this is how I'm seeing it
but is this how you're seeing it what
this is what I think the facts are what
do you think the facts are helps people
just remain open and feel okay this
person is listening to me instead of us
saying you're being this I can't believe
how much you are like this or you made
me feel this way it changes the entire
mood of the entire of the conversation
when we change just those simple ways
that we frame things yeah it really does
and it's a lovely way to approach things
aiming is one human into another just to
find a place of you know can we find a
connection can we find a sense of uh of
understanding and you know it's been
something that I've worked really hard
on figuring out for myself and and
really enjoy seeing it for other people
to see that breakthroughs that can
happen for them and the Ripple effects
and I find that if somebody learns how
to do it in one situation it can change
many others and the first time I
remember seeing this was that there was
a lady that we were working with who was
at a financial company we coached her
for how to interact with her clients in
a more effective way and then I came
back to work with their team about six
months later they said to me as as
people were coming in she she hadn't
arrived yet but her team had and they
said do you know what's happened for
Sarah and I said no what do you mean and
they said um the way that she approaches
life has changed the way that she her
relationships with her clients has gone
through the roof you know she's so much
more successful there people are wanting
to to work with her recommendations are
going up the way that she interacts with
all of us has changed her marriage has
improved she's feeling happy here with
her children and it was one of the first
moments where I thought oh it tips over
into every aspect once you start to get
this piece working for you you can use
it in all different areas yes and like
you said about parenting it completely
relates to Parenting so much of the way
that we talk to our children can be it's
helpful for us to see how to talk to
children when we realize how we want to
be talked to because if we talk to our
children in a certain way and then we
say let's see how would that play out if
I spoke to an adult that way would that
go very well or would that actually
cause some heightened anxiety or a big
burst of emotion or a big response and
children are people too they're people
now they're not becoming people they're
people now and we're all interconnected
and the way that our children are
experiencing life affects how they're
gonna act as adults so if they're
already feeling as a child I oh so much
of my podcast episodes that aren't even
about parenting end up going back to
Parenting at least somehow do you know
yeah because it really it impacts how
they're becoming as an adult this whole
conversation the way that our children
are learning how to communicate affects
how they're going to be able to
communicate as adults or what might
bring anxiety for them that um told them
through past experiences that it's not
safe to have their feelings or you know
being closed up when the conflict comes
up and all that so I guess my next
question is do you think people have
become less amicable and less able to
resolve conflict now unless human in how
they're interacting it just seems like a
lot of people don't have high confidence
in communication with others absolutely
this has been really a compelling
journey to watch so I've been leading my
company now for the last 23 years
coaching we've coached over I think it's
like 120 000 people we've coached
worldwide working with all sorts of
different Industries people from student
level up to CEO and everything in
between and over the years I've seen
this big Journey this sort of shift of
what the needs are in communication and
what I've noticed that the last few
years is that people have gone from
wanting more help around things like
doing a speech or preparing for a job
interview or going to do a presentation
or things like that there's been a shift
towards a lot of requests around
conflict resolution and I was really
curious about well why is that happening
suddenly now our team put together a
survey that we did and I think we
included something like 2 000 people in
this survey and we found that it's true
that people feel less able to less
confident to communicate less able to
resolve conflicts and people are less
amicable with each other we just have
more of these sort of siled views and I
think that this is part of the ripple
effect that's happened from the pandemic
where we went from being in a place
where we used to be rubbing shoulders
with a whole variety of people every day
and needing to get along with with so
many different people who are sharing
our space all the time we then went to a
place where there was almost you know a
sort of a fear built of getting outside
and of being with with others and also
being trapped in our own space and then
when we started to you know go out again
to build relationships there was a
distance and I've noticed this is kind
of a strange thing in different places
that I go to I look at people thinking
like before the pandemic I would have
given you a hug but are we going to do a
handshake or is there like do we just
wave you know what's happening here
there's that sort of space that's being
created between people as a result of
that people have also you know social
media is partly feeding into this where
we just you know we like the things that
we like and then the algorithm only
sends you the sort of things that you
like and we think okay well everybody
must think this way then and then when
you meet somebody outside of that you're
less used to you're less practiced in
working on those sort of situations and
again to go back to the to the exercise
analogy I think quite a lot of people
put on a few pounds over the pandemic by
yourself sitting at home and less
working out and I certainly did I used
to travel the world a lot and be
carrying suitcases through airports
every day and then sat on my couch at
the end of each day not needing to
travel and eating too much food I needed
to then get out there and and and build
up my fitness my physical fitness and
people need to do this with their
emotional Fitness as well one simple way
of doing that is to think you know I see
this with people p even people who
wanted to go out every weekend they
would have social plans for the morning
the lunch evening they'd have other
things in the in in the week as well
I've seen some of those people become
very much homebodies but they think I
don't I don't really want to leave the
house it's going to take me half an hour
to drive to go and have dinner with that
person maybe I just won't and that's
happened for people who I never would
have expected that to be the case and so
because we're spending less time
physically with each other we're having
less of that practice like going to the
emotional gym each day and so therefore
we're less prepared when tough
situations and conversations uh come up
and so that's when my my team have
needed to step into various different
organizations and help them get to the
place where they are able to resolve
conflict and and some of that is also
because of virtual working where people
used to be able to just sort of sit in a
room with each other or just sit down
and grab a coffee and they would resolve
things where these days they may not
even see each other from one month to
the next in the same physical space and
so we're having to strengthen our
ability to use techniques that can bring
us together with a sense of connection
and understanding in a way that
previously we may have just felt like
you know we were able to easily do
things without even thinking we're doing
it like we're breathing and this is
where I've just been feeling so grateful
recently for this different lens that I
have on communication to to neurotypical
people I've always found it's difficult
to figure out how do those two people
get on and those other two people don't
get on like what is happening in that
interaction how do I break this down and
turn it into a system that my brain can
understand which has now become useful
for people to say this is the thing you
used to do when you're doing it like you
were breathing you know you can just go
through these steps and suddenly you can
move back in the right place and it
might feel weird but just like going to
the gym you need to build up your
strength in that space and be prepared
to have those tougher conversations as
you build up your skills again yeah when
you say build up your skills it makes me
think of this explanation of how a
healthy communication can happen it
might sound really daunting for people
to expect themselves to communicate like
that all of a sudden you know like I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to do
that when I have heightened emotions but
it really just takes practice bit by bit
and then it will become second nature it
will become like breathing because the
more you practice something the more
normal it becomes and what you said
about the pandemic was really
interesting and thought provoking
because there are certain things like
for instance
um at Target or Lowe's big box stores
where during the pandemic they started
certain routines like you don't even
have to get out of your car to get your
things just stay in the car we'll come
bring it to you those types of things
caused less and less interactions and
now people are doing it more out of
convenience than anything and so we
we're so fast-paced in our world that
we're thinking what's the easiest most
convenient a way to get the things done
and oftentimes that becomes things that
require less human interaction which is
fascinating in the detrimental effects
it can have yeah and it's it's funny
because I've been asked a question I
think for quite a few years you know
long long before the pandemic happened
uh where people have said to me oh
Richard you teach communication do you
think that uh you know what you teach is
going to become irrelevant or obsolete
is more and more things happen you know
in a way that automated with you know
robots or machines or you know you check
into a hotel and you don't even need to
see the reception desk it's like a you
know ticketless check-in or whatever
you're doing and I've had to say to
people all along I think that what we
teach is going to become so much more
important because people will have less
practice and if you look at you know
even the generation of kids that are
growing up today where you know back in
the day when when I was younger if you
have a sleepover you just talk to each
other you know you might watch a movie
in chat and sort of back and forth and
so on you'd have one screen that you're
looking at your Channel into each other
or you just talk all night whereas you
know these days as we know as a lot of
people talk about you get a group of
kids together and they're all separately
on their own screens and they're not
actually doing the interaction part and
the big challenge with that is that it
leads to as I was mentioning earlier
that state of loneliness a state of
feeling disconnected from others and
there's nothing that makes us feel more
fulfilled and wanted than that sense of
feeling connected to our tribe whoever
our tribe may be and so I think that you
know people are going to need to work
more and more on these ironically named
soft skills they're not soft they're not
easy they are hard skills but we need to
work on them because they're critical
for us to to feel fulfilled as a human
being yeah I've done an entire episode
on the dangers of smartphones for kids I
am very against smartphones for young
children I mean I don't need to say it
so strong like that but I just think it
causes so many problems in our society
especially with their developing brains
I think being on a smartphone is
addicting for an adult let alone a young
child with a developing brain and
especially with the way that social
media has turned into just more and more
stimulation and smaller and smaller
attention spans I was talking to a
friend about this a while ago that it
seems like the the most popular way to
consume media besides movies in the past
used to be like a talk show and then it
was a reality show which has a lot more
heightened emotions and then after that
it became like Vlogs on YouTube and then
after that it became Tick Tock reels now
it's getting smaller and smaller just 90
second five second 10 second
stimulations that when you put the phone
down suddenly the world that you're in
is no longer stimulating even if you're
with someone around you you might be
tempted to just get on your phone when
you have people in the room around you
which causes so much disconnection and
the need for you know this conversation
on the importance of communication yeah
so many things come to mind in that one
of them is that a few years ago I took
our eldest son Max I took him to Ghana
into the western Africa we went to North
Ghana and at the beginning of the week I
think that you know in in society and
we're very mindful of you know keeping
our children away from screen or
reducing screen time beginning of the
week I noticed with him when we're out
in Ghana where they don't have all of
the
um great Comforts that we're used to
here he'd be just slightly uh agitated
and needing some stimulation of some
sort on the bus as we went from one
place to the next to visit a village or
see a project that we were supporting
and within about three days he got to
the point where he you know he'd be on
this minibus that was boiling hot in the
middle of nowhere on a bumpy road and
he'd just be really happily looking out
the window and thinking wow I just I'm
just taking in the world and it made me
think about how overstimulated we are
day after day and you know then looking
at how this works as adults like you
said that the version of shows that have
how that's transpired to where we are
now of you know people putting together
15 second reels and you know people
people turn off the Reel within three
seconds if it's not good enough I was
doing a podcast episode with somebody
where it was all business focused and I
think it was more sort of sales focused
entrepreneurial and I was talking
through a story about how my team and I
had helped an organization a big
engineering company win a deal that was
worth nearly a billion dollars and I'd
been talking about explaining how we did
it and I'd been talking for maybe 90
seconds and the guy cut me off and he
said uh just so you know uh this is
going on a bit long could you just cut
it down and my brain thought what are
you what are you talking about you're
saying that if it takes more than 90
seconds to find out how to make a
billion dollars people aren't interested
anymore like is that what you're saying
you know one of the challenges that
comes up
yeah it's far too long I'm only
interested if you can teach me in 12
seconds wow there's a piece that our
brain does that that we like to process
the world through story and we know that
we we see that through social media and
TV and anything that grabs our attention
we process the world through story but
one of the challenges we have to be
aware of in story is the Montage
sequence so you know when you you know
sort of watching a movie where somebody
has a big challenge they've got a goal
they want to achieve and one day they go
I'm going to go for it and what happens
is a song starts playing and that song
lasts a maximum of three minutes and
during that three minutes they do
everything they would possibly need to
do to overcome all of the physical
emotional and spiritual challenges they
need to get through to get to the point
of being the world's greatest champion
of something because we've seen that so
many times I see this happening in
challenges where people have uh Conflict
at work or in a relationship of some
sort where they think well once I've
made a decision that it will be fixed if
it's not fixed within three minutes then
it's impossible and it's it's very
frustrating and and actually where we
need to do the work is in the Montage
sequence where it's important if we're
going to have healthy relationships with
people around us to understand our story
and their story and by which to simplify
it I say you know it's important for
everyone to know if you're the hero at
the center of your own story what are
your challenges right now what are the
things that are keeping you aware awake
at night that you care about or that
maybe they're not that bad right now but
if nothing changes they're going to be
bad what are those things for you and
what are the goals that you would love
to achieve uh what would be so
meaningful for you a year from now 10
years from now which might be that you
want your life to be exactly the way it
is right now or just without that one or
two challenges so whatever that is for
you figure out what that is for you now
if you want to have a strong
relationship with somebody else find out
what the story is for them they're the
hero at the center of their own
experience what what are they what are
their challenges what are their goals
what does that look like and when you
figure that out you know what Journey
you are going on and you know what
Journey they are going on and that
Journey doesn't happen within three
minutes of listening to a fun song
so you've got that long journey to take
but at least if you understand what
their end uh dream goal would be and
what your end dream vision would be for
working together or a relationship
together or where you'd like to be by
the end of you know next year in some
some way then you can take that journey
mindfully together having good
conversations about the journey along
the way and not expect it to happen
instantly not expect it to happen in the
space of a tweet it's going to take time
and that's good because the journey is
is really the point as people often say
the journey is where you get the growth
that allows you to enjoy the end results
so allowing yourself and the other
person the time and the patience to put
in the work there is really important
and I found this important in my my
marriage I've been married to this uh
beautiful woman who you know Gemma uh
and we've been together now 20 years and
to think that you know you boy and girl
meets and you get married and you live
happily ever after it's ridiculous does
just know what it is but if you have a
United Vision of where you would love to
be in the future then you can patiently
go on the journey together overcome the
obstacles have the conversations that
need to be had so you resolve things
along the way as you grow together
towards whatever that future is that you
would love to build yes so much of what
you just said especially just those
little pieces like all coming together
as a bigger picture for on the one hand
I see the short attention spans the
attention grabbing type of information
that we're drawn to to always look for
the instant gratification and then on
the other hand I think about your son
looking through the window on the bus
just being in the present moment being
patient enjoying what his real
surroundings are and being grateful for
every moment taking your time with
fruitful conversations and not rushing
it I mean just that podcast example
where someone's telling you 90 seconds
is too long hurry speed it up I mean if
that doesn't show us what's happening in
our society like I mean it's just that's
just insane the importance of
conversation and staying present and not
rushing things cannot be overstated I
think in this topic of the art of
communication and I think it is a good
segue into the topic of mental health
and communication can you explain to us
if there's a correlation there because
before I let you answer there's a recent
article that my husband and I were
looking at talking about how much screen
time kids are on these days compared to
in the past and right now I think it
said the average screen time use for 12
to 17 year olds was something about
eight hours a day or ten hours a day and
that doesn't even include school work
that was non-schoolwork type of screen
time and at the same time mental health
issues are on the rise depression is on
the rise Suicidal Thoughts Are On The
Rise and it's so clear to me what is
happening to us and I'm a little bit
nervous about the future if it continues
on this trajectory so yeah let's get
into mental health and communication
when it comes to mental health and and
to communication if you think about that
take the analogy of the screen where
let's imagine that whatever screen or
device that you have you open up 300
apps that are all uh operating at the
same time uh inevitably the system that
the device is going to crash because
there's too much stuff sort of fighting
for uh the the memory space and the
energy and so it's going to crash and
the same sort of thing can happen to us
day to day and this has happened a lot
more during the course of the last
couple of years where people were people
went from in 2019 having whatever job
they had to then for so many people
having that same job but needing to
figure out how to do it at home through
Virtual Technology as well as uh looking
after their children and sharing the
internet with four other people and
trying to figure out how to get their
cat out of the way while they're doing a
virtual meeting and so all of these
different things that are going on
causing this sense of stress and
overwhelm while people also were
searching for a sense of purpose
thinking I don't even know why I'm doing
this why did I show up to this job in
the first place so there's all these
sort of different stresses that are
coming our way and
for me during that time period uh this
is where I figured out a few things that
that I eventually captured in this book
that I've just written where I went
through a huge challenge where for for
me in my business with all sorts of
stress coming my way if you think back
to like 2019 the world was open and my
my business model was that uh 70 of my
work for my for me and my team involved
getting on an airplane we couldn't do it
unless we could get on an airplane 70 of
the time and travel across to Australia
or South Korea or wherever we're going
in Canada wherever we went and 100 of
our work involved being in an enclosed
area with a group of people all of that
was made illegal we couldn't get on a
plane we couldn't see people face to
face and so people were coming to me me
and my company saying we're going to go
out of business like we've got lots of
bills going out we've got lots of people
on the payroll we've got a big fancy
expensive London office that we're not
even allowed to walk through the front
door of we have huge Bills going out and
nothing literally nothing coming in
every thing was canceled and there were
people in my industry that I know were
buckling under that sort of situation
and at the same time what we faced as a
business
something we'd never experienced before
is that there was then a a small group
of people who decided that they would
try and attack our business for our
clients they were hacking into our
database lots of criminal activity was
involved of them trying to steal our
clients while we were just trying to
figure out like could we even survive as
a team could we get through this
situation and you know for me my mental
health was really being challenged uh by
this situation there was greater
problems after greater problems coming
up each day and a lot of people looking
at me uh for you know for me to provide
to my for my family for me to provide
for my team and to to serve my clients
who were then needing us but not knowing
how they were going to work with us and
I felt deeply deeply challenged and so
what I decided to do is that each day I
got up really early I'd sometimes get up
at 5am sometimes 5 30 and the first 90
minutes of the day was my time to get my
mental health back to where it needed to
be and so the first 45 minutes I would
spend in deep meditation and if you
think about it going back to the device
analogy it's like shutting all of the
apps down
getting back to the point of there being
a blank screen and being able to have
total Clarity and allowing myself to
release the previous day release a
connection or a need for any certain
results to show up that day and get to a
point of being centered uh where I would
do deep breathing I would really focus
hard in on what my values are in life
the kind of person that I want to be
knowing that if I live those values
between the moment that people started
to call me that day and going to sleep
that night I could live with it I
couldn't control what was happening I
couldn't control what was going on in
the world in the industry but I could
control my values and my actions there
so I do that for 45 minutes I then would
do 45 minutes worth of movement where I
found this really wonderful version of
movement that's almost like a like a
Dance Yoga is the best expression I can
give of it but what it allowed you to do
what it was focused on is helping you
connect with all of the elements
so different movements that you do to
connect to a sense of fire or water or
Earth or air and it allowed me to feel
more whole as I then started the day and
so I was then in a place where I could
bring the better version of me into the
day and the final part of that process
for me was having a really compelling
Vision so I found this in in dark
moments in the past where I've been
under what I would think of as the dark
cloud or the darkest in the darkest Cave
of thinking do I really want to be here
anymore and that was where the pain of
being here was feeling too much and the
the pain of not being here felt uh like
a more comfortable situation and so what
I realized is being true to my values
knowing what they are and then having
such a compelling Vision that I truly
believed in as a better version of the
future that I would walk towards and I
would just aim to do one thing each day
that would move me towards that uh North
Star Vision as I call it and by doing
that by living by my values and taking
one step to towards that North Star
Vision that's all I needed is that
glimmer of hope of I'm now able to to
make progress to make the world better
for the people around me in some way to
serve them and that was very positive
for my mental health to think okay I'm
I'm taking charge of my mind I'm taking
charge of being The Rock in the storm
able to thrive and then I can show up to
very challenging conversations
very challenging decisions that need to
be made so that my my team and I and my
my family and I we can not only survive
but Thrive through this situation and I
was able to show up and communicate in
the way that I wanted to as well what I
also needed to do is to communicate that
North Star Vision in a way that my team
believed in because there are people on
my team thinking we should go in
different directions I needed to come
from a place of total certainty
committed to my values when there was no
way of me knowing if I was making the
right decision but just thinking these
are my values this is the North Star
Vision this is the next step that we
take and being exceptionally clear with
people in making sure that that happened
and you know at long story short on on
doing that is I got to from a place
where I was feeling uh absolutely
devastated depressed anxious getting to
a place of feeling very centered very
clear
able to look after my family and my team
and we grew every year in an era in an
era where other companies were really
struggling were able to you know still
move things forward so what I learned
through that is that you know when when
I was putting together this this new
book that I've got about communication I
thought I can't dive straight into
communication that that would be
ridiculous particularly in this day and
age and need to spend a good portion of
time talking about getting people to a
state of mind where they are able to
have really effective communication with
others because if you just say to
someone okay say these things and use
your body language in this way and it
will work it won't because there are
elements in their their mindset and
their mental health that may be holding
them back from that that they need to
work on first such that they can be a
really positive influence on others
mm-hmm thanks for sharing that and
you're so right it's more than just
words and Body Language it's an energy
that you can feel from the person so if
you're not feeling well and centered in
your life it's going to show up in your
conversations so that's amazing thank
you for thank you for all those tips can
you talk a little bit about your book
then so so people can know if it's the
right book for them to to dig into sure
thanks yeah so uh this new book is
called lift your impacts wait I've got a
copy of this here there's one of these
on its way to you Ellen which is coming
up yes I can't wait to read it
uh so so I wrote this book uh where it I
I wrote it based on
wanting to help people feel that they're
they're living a more meaningful life
and they're getting what they need and
it was really based on the last few
years where I noticed a lot of people
who previously hadn't expressed these
challenges but the last few years have
said that they're feeling stressed
they're feeling lonely and they're
feeling a lack of purpose and and that
could be true in any sort of situation
whether you're in the workplace you're a
business owner entrepreneur you're a
parent you know whatever is your
situation and I wanted to work on those
three areas to help people have a really
powerful mindset so that you start each
day being the best version of you able
to to show up and and be the way you'd
like to be in key situations once you've
done that then the next piece uh to to
look at to overcome that sense of
feeling lonely is to look at how do you
build deeper connections deeper
relationships with the people around you
so you're really positive influence uh
on any anybody whose life that you touch
you may not always agree with with
people and there can be conflict that
comes up but being the most positive
influence you can be through various
different strategies I've worked on with
clients and then the final piece that I
was really passionate about is thinking
you know there's so many people who felt
lost the last few years there's been the
great resignation there's been a lot of
people not wanting to go back to work or
deciding to start their own business
potentially or starting new projects and
initiatives and what we know about this
was it's very clear everybody knows that
you can make a New Year's resolution and
then by the end of January it's just
disappeared like it just it hasn't held
for one reason or another so I wanted to
make sure that if people want to live a
more meaningful life that they've got a
way of
being very clear about their North Star
Vision but also understanding the pieces
that need to happen in order to get
there in the end and so I've talked
about a couple of pieces in there uh
that I love sharing with people so one
of those pieces about long-term success
is I talk about the need to do things
that are pivotal and the things that are
pedestrian and so as an example of this
um you know Gemma who's been on your
podcast she's the plant power doctor she
went from never having been on Instagram
uh to within a couple of years having
nearly a hundred thousand followers at
this point and there were certain
pivotal things that happened along the
way so at one point she was invited to
uh be a guest on the Rich Roll podcast
which is he's a brilliant guy I love his
podcast and uh people were then asking
her immediately afterwards lots of
people on the network said can you get
me on the podcast how do I get on the
podcast if only I could go on the
podcast that would be the next step for
me uh that would be my my my ticket to
uh success and what I really admire
about the way that she shows up in the
world is that she's not just focusing on
those pivotal pieces she's doing The
Pedestrian piece as well and that's what
a lot of people miss when they're aiming
to achieve their North Star vision is
that people might think if only I could
get on Oprah or if only I could get this
you know million dollar book deal then I
will have made it and they're looking at
the pivotal pieces but they're not
looking at The Pedestrian things of what
needs to happen every single day such
that I would be exactly the right choice
the inevitable choice for those pivotal
moments
looking at the other side of that you
also get some people who they're doing
The Pedestrian piece every day but
they're never looking up thinking about
what would be the pivotal part that I
could do that would take me up to the
next level you know where what what sort
of level am I at now what am I deserving
of as a pivotal opportunity where I
could go to this next stage so looking
at both of those pieces is really
important uh to get people to where they
want to be and the last piece that I
like to talk about is in terms of
momentum behind things is when people
set a goal
they could be doing pivotal and
pedestrian things but still sort of burn
out because of a couple of reasons so I
like to talk to people about three
things they can they can focus on to hit
those long-term goals uh whatever that
may be for them improving communication
uh getting to a certain level of Fitness
or you know building their business
whatever it is I talk about commitment
action and routine commitment action and
routine so commitment means that you
decide in your North Star Vision a big
long-term commitment something that
matters to you it's not something that
Society has chosen for you or your
parents have told you is a good idea
it's something where you think if I'm
living my by my values the ultimate
realization of my values would be in
this Direction that's where I want to
get to my long-term commitment
in order to make sure that you feel like
you're making progress you need daily
actions and if you do daily actions
towards it you shift your identity you
are no longer who you used to be you are
becoming the identity of the person who
achieves whatever this is in the future
and then inevitably we get knocked off
track sometimes we just wake up and we
think I don't want to do this anymore I
don't feel like I make any progress I'm
not getting anywhere and so it's
worthwhile to have a routine or a ritual
that gets you back into the state that
you need to be in order to make progress
uh whether that is a piece of music that
you can play that gets you back into
State uh for me are we uh we hosted a
retreat last year
that I love doing where we got people to
release old stories that were holding
them back and create new stories that
would Empower them in their future and
we gathered around a fire we burned
those old stories and we let them go and
we burned sage and Pala Santo at the
same time and we were sort of infusing
ourselves with those scents in that
moment and for six months after I'd had
that experience If Ever I was having a
moment where I could film my old story
creeping back in I would just sit
quietly with my eyes closed and pick up
the sage in Palo Santo and get back into
the state that I felt on that day and
remind myself why I'm moving forwards in
a New Direction and so you can do all
these sorts of things just to bring
yourself back to a good version of
yourself as you move forward to the life
that you're aiming to create I cannot
wait to read this book it's going to be
so good and I think it's just helpful
for
so many people even just those little
reminders of centering yourself when you
find yourself going to the what ifs if
this goes here the fear the ego the way
that we want to react to things and just
reminding ourselves to Center ourselves
and slow down in our conversations not
being quick to react and just it all
it's all tied in together to the way
that you lift your impact on your life
so thank you yeah thanks and importantly
this was something I was so pleased my
publisher agreed to I've made the book a
workbook so uh so that people can make
it their own book they make it their own
Journey they're really doing the work on
you know anything I've talked about on
here and talk about elsewhere I wanted
to be there as their coach and guide
them through and say just stop for a
minute don't don't read any further just
get out of pen and and work through this
piece with me so that people can really
feel like they get a transformation not
just get inspiration uh from that piece
so I was really pleased I was able to
put that in the book too
so to round out this conversation then
we went through a portion of this uh
conversation on how to navigate
discussions with a partner or friend or
work colleague where it becomes a
heightened emotion and how to keep it
calm and peaceful but what about someone
who would like to speak with friends and
people in their life on discourse and
things that they disagree with like the
politics religion uh or meaning of life
as the examples you gave earlier and how
you can give or what strategies you can
give people to navigate those
conversations and start to enjoy the
conversation and show up as their best
self and to be able to be authentic and
how they feel they don't have to just
nod their head and agree with the person
in front of them because they're afraid
to say what they really think so I mean
I'm I'm always Keen to encourage people
to feel that they can really Express
themselves and find their voice in
situations one of the simplest
techniques that you can use in order to
build your confidence there is to make
sure that when whenever you're with a
group of people where you'd love to have
your voice heard is to make sure that
you have you've said something early on
so that you feel like you are part of
this conversation the conversation isn't
happening and you have to sort of find
the on-rem you're already part of this
conversation uh back and forth and uh I
noticed this uh when many years back I
was involved a couple of times with some
some marketing where people would get
together a focus group and they try and
figure out you know what does this focus
group think about our new brand that
we're launching and what I noticed is
that as I was sitting there part of
these focus groups is that the first two
or three people who spoke ended up being
the only people who spoke for most of
the hour and there was a facilitator
saying hey Bob in the corner do you want
to offer something they go no no it's
it's fine you guys you guys just talk
whereas it was the people who spoke
early on who then ended up guiding and
influencing what that brand would become
and so on and so it's important when
you're in conversation with people where
you sort of you join a dinner party or
you get together with people where where
you want to have your voice heard if
it's in a meeting is to be able to
contribute early on so that you
consciously you think to yourself okay
I'm part of this conversation and also
what it starts to do is it settles the
monkey mind
so we have this uh monkey mind as it's
often referred to that is just trying to
keep us safe and this monkey mind says
terrible things to us that puts us off
in our communication and so it'll say
things to us along the lines of uh these
people don't like you they'll never
respect you that they shouldn't have
given you the job and they know it and
you'll never get that promotion why did
you wear that today you look awful you
should leave the building leave the
building right now and what it's doing
is it's got this survival Instinct All
That Monkey mind voice cares about is
keeping you alive for the next five
minutes uh it's not there to be your
friend it's not there to be your life
coach it doesn't care about if you're
happy or not it just wants to keep you
safe and so what it's aiming to do often
is back in the day of saber-toothed
tigers it was very useful because if you
felt a bit stressed it would say leave
now run run run run run and it kept you
alive because you run away from the
saber-toothed tiger these days it shows
up when you get into a conversation and
you think I'm feeling a bit stressed
about opening up and sharing my opinion
and the monkey mind says leave the
building right now I'm going to tell you
terrible things about yourself until you
shut up and you don't say anything and
you leave the building and so we need to
soothe the monkey mind and make sure
that we're able to settle it down so we
can speak so one of the simple things
you can do is if you speak early on in a
meeting and you just share share a view
at a safe sort of level whatever you
feel comfortable with the monkey mind
suddenly realizes hang on a second I
shared something and nobody hates me and
so that's okay so this is kind of a safe
situation so it starts to settle down
and allows you to open up with more of
your potential then you can start to
open up a little bit more what I also
would encourage people to do
as you're starting to speak early on in
a conversation is rather than think
about I want to express my view you can
think of yourself more being curious of
other people's opinions and this is how
you can become a linchpin in a team
meeting with colleagues and so on don't
go in there with saying this is my
opinion on everything instead be there
as someone who's really curious with
others like oh that's really fascinating
I'd love to know more about how you feel
about this and what about this situation
what do you think when people see it
this way so you're Gathering a sense of
the context of how others feel and what
the position of the opinions are in the
room before you then bring in and say
well you know actually I've got a
completely different opinion and I loved
hearing yours and here's something I'd
like to add into this so you're coming
from a perspective of you've got
information people feel respected by you
they feel heard by you and so they will
reciprocate with that sense of hearing
you back so you've settled your monkey
mind down you've also gained rapport
with the people in the room and then you
can join in that conversation expressing
whatever opinion you need to express you
sort of build your way into that
situation and and by so doing people
will enjoy your contribution rather than
you sort of feeling like I'm just going
to show up and talk about my opinion
from the beginning and you don't know
where things are going to go so it's a
nice easy way to get into there and to
build a relationship with the other
people in the in the room
meaning opening
part is one of the biggest inspectors to
a healthy
education a healthy conversation on a
particular topic that you disagree
disagree with rather than going saying
I'm right I know what the answer is
remaining curious listening to the what
the other person says and responding to
it with your own ideas in a respectful
way that isn't blaming or saying You
must be this this or this if you don't
agree with me you know the the posture
of I'm open I want to hear what you have
to say and I also have other thoughts
and like you said calming the monkey
brain I love that analogy of I'm safe
this person likes me and loves me
um even if I disagree with them and that
kind of reminder and but you know they
might have had experiences in the past
where someone a loved one in their life
doesn't didn't love them if they express
their opinions which I think is actually
quite common for people as adults have
memories as a child like that and that
can be a really good reminder for
parents in this up in this conversation
think about how you are speaking to your
children or do your children feel safe
to to express their feelings and do you
have a space for them especially as they
get older and start having their own
opinions to let them Express their own
opinions are you going to make that a
safe place for them and that can help
them as they get older to feel safe to
express their their feelings in adult
conversations as they become adults and
then the other factor that I think is uh
actually just a key piece that maybe
I've had with people in my life who I
I've spoken to about okay so what is the
reason why you generally avoid disagree
like conversations with a disagreement
on a specific topic and sometimes they
might say well it's partly because I
know I disagree with this person but I
don't know why I don't know how to
express that I disagree with them I
don't really know exactly why I just
know I disagree with them so what are
your thoughts on that because my initial
thoughts on that are okay well then
maybe there's a posture of there's more
for me to learn than I realize and maybe
I shouldn't have such a strong opinion
on a specific thing if I don't really
know why I feel that way and to be sure
to take the time to listen to all
different perspectives on this
particular issue or topic so that I can
feel really confident in my perspective
on it but do you think there's more to
it and maybe it just depends on each
person some people have an easier time
expressing and communicating in that way
or yeah like what are there other
factors to that
yeah there could certainly be other
factors in this situation and this is
where you know I love that you you bring
parenting in into conversations like
this because you know the way that we
learn to communicate starts very young
and and our sense of emotional safety
with expressing ourselves and and being
various different ways starts very young
and so it's important for anybody as a
parent uh listening into this as I'm
sure they would if they if they listen
to you then they're going to have had
great parenting advice already but to
remember that you know when we see our
child uh behaving in a way that is
destructive in some way to make sure
that that we don't Place judgment on
them for for being a certain way and
saying this is the right way to be this
is the wrong way to be if you behave
that way you're this sort of person
because when those sort of things happen
to us when we're younger we we feel
ashamed of a certain aspect of ourselves
which becomes very challenging to deal
with and so the jungian psychology way
of talking about this is to say that if
you look at a whole being part of
ourselves then gets put into what's
known as The Shadow so we sort of
pretend that that part of ourselves
doesn't exist and we make sure that it
never shows up in in any situation
because we're we're fearful that we'll
be judged and we'll be deemed to be a
bad person if that part of ourselves is
ever seen by someone which is crazy to
think about because we've got so many
different ways that we think about life
that we see life actions that we could
take thoughts that we have that we never
act on it doesn't make us a bad person
but if we have negative judgment on it
what can happen is that sometimes you
find yourself in conflict with somebody
else
and part of that conflict is that
without you realizing it they are
triggering a reflection of your Shadow
as in you see something about how they
are acting behaving or thinking that
when you were younger maybe your parents
may be Society maybe your religion maybe
something said to you behaving that way
thinking that way acting that way is
wrong and so you've denied that part of
yourself and you see part of that
behavior showing up in someone else and
suddenly you you feel like this is
terrible and I can't speak to this
person because you're afraid of part of
yourself and so we need to come to terms
with well if I'm being triggered by this
person what part of myself am I feeling
a sense of Shame about or that I haven't
really sort of integrated as being okay
and an aspect of me that I don't choose
to express but I know that it's part of
me and so it's important sometimes you
can look through sort of various
questions you can ask yourself about
some somebody if you feel negatively
towards them and you're not really sure
why you can think well what is so wrong
with being the way that they are or
thinking the way that they think what is
wrong with that and you know ultimately
what could that lead to for that person
what do we think is the worst possible
outcome of thinking that way being that
way doing things that way then you can
flip it over and think about yourself
and think well what is it that I do
that stops me from being that way what
do I do that's the opposite of that how
do I stop myself from expressing myself
in that way so you're sort of showing
how you are covering up that behavior
and denying that part of yourself and
then last the last part of this I I'm uh
making it concise but the last part of
this is simply that you think if I
allowed myself
to accept part of their view or to
behave in some way like they do
what good things could that bring into
my life if I allowed myself to be more
whole if I allowed myself to think
somehow along the lines that they do is
there anything positive that could come
to me that I'm currently not
experiencing and when you do this it
helps you have total empathy for their
position because you think well maybe
there are some benefits of thinking that
way feeling that way behaving that way
and it also allows you to uncover
aspects of yourself that you were not
prepared to accept so it can be a
wonderful thing to do because if there's
somebody who is irritating you and you
just don't know why
getting away from that person isn't
going to help avoiding the conversation
isn't going to help because that's going
to show up again and again as you are
triggered again and again by part of you
that you've put into your Shadow so it's
worthwhile thinking what is it really
where is this coming from what's so bad
about it how do I try not to be like it
what if I did allow part of myself to go
in that direction and so you get to a
sense of
um of of release and of acceptance of
yourself and of people who are behaving
in such a way so it can be a really
positive way forward for you and for
them
something that I just thought of through
all of our examples like we we could
also touch on what what about those who
are listening going okay yes I hear you
but when I try to get in conversations
with this person or this person specific
people in their life it's very unhealthy
because of the way that they are acting
they don't they don't do a good job at
remaining calm they keep like a lot
there's a lot of heightened emotions and
judgment and anxiety so what do I do in
those scenarios do I just choose not to
have those conversations what what's
your suggestion there
yeah so uh so importantly when we
approach a conversation where we feel it
it's not going to work out well
um key again to come back to centering
yourself before you go into that
conversation and get curious about what
would make this conversation easier for
that person what would create a safe
space for them what are they missing and
aiming to feel curious about what is it
that could be triggering that fear so in
that situation they are coming into the
interaction with you with a fear-based
response or a pain-based response and
your intention if you want to speak to
them is to get to a place where where
things are working out well so it's
worthwhile reflecting on yourself
thinking is there something that I'm
doing in this situation that could be
making that person feel unsafe and is
there a way that I can help them get to
a place where we feel safe to have this
conversation together and so again it's
worthwhile going into those
conversations with no expectations of
making progress and and now not laying a
any importance on progress being made
and this is super important and
something that coaches are very well
aware of if you go into a coaching
session with someone who's feeling
really stressed out and as a coach you
think I must get them to the point by
the end of this coaching session that
they feel wonderful and they've achieved
all their goals then actually
um having that expectation on the
session causes a huge problem so you've
got to make sure you're going with no
expectations but you just come from a
state where you think I'm being centered
in myself my intention is loving and
peaceful towards this person and all I
want to do right now is just make a
little incremental step which is not
resolving it but finding curiosity about
what could we do that would get us to a
place where we can have a more
comfortable conversation and part of
that can be as I've learned with you
know running my team is that some people
really like it if there's a challenge
that they can have the information
written down and then we come and talk
about it other people if I write it down
and then they get really anxious about
it they get fairly feel stressed out
because they read it over and over in
their mind and they translate it in many
different ways other people prefer a
voice call uh other people prefer to be
sitting face to face other people prefer
to go for a walk so it's about creating
an environment where you can be with
that person that's going to have them
feel most at ease so approaching them
with a sense of intention of saying you
know I'd really like to get to a place
where we can have a positive
relationship and I'd love to know what
would make you most comfortable in
having that conversation is it something
that you'd like to have now is it
something that maybe we could do next
week and if we did what situation would
work for you so that you are moving
forward in a way that shows that you are
accepting and listening and
understanding of their needs another
piece that needs to be addressed here
though is also to think about some
boundaries around this piece of what is
okay and what isn't okay and to know
that it's perfectly acceptable to set
boundaries around things of what sort of
behaviors you're okay with and not okay
with
um and to be able to let them know that
and also boundaries in in what you're
agreeing to so sometimes somebody might
say look based on our relationship and
the way things are going I want this and
it may be something that you you you
can't give them you can't agree to and
and that's okay to have that
disagreement
sometimes what we're looking for in
these conflict situations is what's
known as Zopa Zopa being an acronym of a
zone of possible agreement and if you
can figure out what that zone of
possible agreement is that you can sort
of edge towards that can be very
powerful and one of the ways to set that
is to give people an umbrella
conversation where you say look
I'd really like to work well with you or
I'd really like to have a better
relationship with you and you can set a
boundary around the conversation saying
given that
which might be uh you know given that we
have got this big
Thanksgiving celebration coming up in
two days time where we're going to be
with all of our family and so on and
we're going to be spending the weekend
together given that this is coming up
what could we do between now and then
that gets us into a better place or if
it's in a work situation you could say
given that we have to complete this
project by the end of October what what
is it that would help you feel
um more uh productive in that situation
or have a better relationship with me so
you can put umbrellas around things with
the given that sort of statement so the
key thing really is to let the person
know your intention to always approach
through your body language or tone of
voice with a sense of what feeling would
you like them to have by the end of the
conversation and then to have patience
too something that I've learned which is
like a final tidbit advice to put on
this piece is that sometimes you see no
progress in a conversation and yet
progress was made and what I mean by
that is if you are patient you have an
intention that is positive towards the
other person your speak looking uh with
the intention of having a resolution
even if they leave having been negative
to you throughout the conversation the
fact that you held yourself together
that you were calm and you approach the
conversation it may take them a couple
of days to look back and think
do you know what I'm so grateful that
that person
took the time to speak to me and that
they were calm with me and that they
didn't get flustered when I was angry
I should give that person a second
chance so again being patient not having
the Montage sequence but being patient
that even if you don't seem to be making
progress sometimes you are because the
the transformation happens sometimes
after the conversation
I'm so glad you said all that that is I
think a beautiful way to end this
conversation and I think it just feels
so well-rounded and I love all the tips
that you shared so I I think this is
where we'll end it it's so helpful thank
you so much for everything you shared I
think this is something that's so
important for people that they
experience all throughout their life
with different types of relationships
ones that might be harder to navigate
like this last example you just gave and
other types of conversations where
people just want to be more confident in
the way that they show up in the world
the way they show up with you know their
friendship and and even in their
friendships and even people at work and
relationships so it all is intertwined
and affects how we feel about ourselves
and the posture that we present to
others so thank you
yeah you're really welcome and and
really nicely summed up I so agree that
if you work on your communication skills
then it fundamentally shifts your
ability to connect with each other and
your enjoyment of being alive so uh it's
been lovely to have that conversation
about this with you yes yes thank you so
much for being here we're going to end
it now and I hope everyone enjoyed this
conversation all right bye
another
[Music]